nicolas vidal bonjour merci d'être en
direct sur arte france ce matin leur
face au nombre grandissant de
manifestants contre le passage ni terres
et devant les réticences de certains
français à se faire vacciner emmanuel
macron change de stratégie
fini les discours solennel quelle image
veut donner le président de la
république mais beaux jours de rab
emmanuel macron garrivier influenceurs
je pense qu'il a été inspiré par mc fly
carlito rappelez-vous les galipettes
dans les jardins de l'elysée alors
emmanuel macron vous l'avez dit leur
reste et les t-shirts effectivement pour
nous faire un selphy vidéo avec ce petit
logo discret bien entendu et il est venu
parler à qui dort à moi je crois qu
emmanuel macron il est venu parler
surtout pas aux français pas aux gens
qui manifestent et santé demi de gens
qui manifestent depuis trois semaines
pour trois semaines et demie mais il est
venu parler aux jeunes non vaccinées
dont emmanuel macron il continua sa
remontée est effectivement pour
reprendre la forme c'est sincèrement
alors emmanuel macron il désacralise
totalement la fonction présidentielle je
le dis souvent imaginé un de golf r une
petite toque un histogramme ou un post
facebook
emmanuel macron il est dans cette
communication de start peur est ici
toujours effrayant avec avec lui parce
qu'on voit quand tu descends les marches
et le la question de savoir qu'on me
reste deux marches qu'au fond quoi alors
justement que même avec ma grossesse et
rajeuni on l'a dit avec ce simple
t-shirt
avec également ses réseaux sociaux tik
tok instagram rassurer et convaincre
justement les jeunes ou plutôt un moyen
voilà de les attirer on va dire de
gagner des points surtout qu'il a perdu
beaucoup de popularité auprès de la
jeunesse
depuis l'instauration du pass sanitaires
oui c'est une très bonne question parce
que je pense que c'est le fond de la
question effectivement emmanuel macron
il ya les présidentielles dans quelques
mois huit mois je crois ils sont en
arrière pensée si d'aller chercher des
voix des stocks de bois finalement mais
quand on voit que les jeunes ne votent
pratiquement plus que c'était aux
municipales originale aux
présidentielles emmanuel macron c'est
une très mauvaise stratégie et en plus
c'est le double coup c'est le double
coup de fouet concrètement vous imaginez
la prise de parole un président de la
république sous la vème c'est un acte
très solennelle très très souvent elles
donc l'éditeur il désacralise et puis il
ya autre chose
ils ont ce rappel man revenons quelques
temps en arrière le 12 juillet qu'a
emmanuel macron il dit à l'antenne nous
expliquer avec ce ton martial
verbalement très très agressif et
aujourd'hui le 2 août pardon hier vous
avez ce self vidéo sur tik tok qui
stagne à l'usinage visionner ce
déséquilibre absolue donc emmanuel
macron il est dans la communication il
salle aveugle de totalement et puis le
but est pas atteint le but va pas être
atteint du tout parce que les jeunes
concrètement je suis pas persuadé que ça
va les toucher énormément le message du
manuel macro un saïfi vidéo petit
t-shirt au bord de la piscine à
brégançon
on sait que le président de la
république n'est pas épidémiologistes il
n'est pas non plus médecin il n'a aucune
légitimité en tout cas scientifique pour
répondre on va dire sur
sur certaines questions vaccinale mais
tout de même il essaye justement
d'inciter la jeunesse aller se faire
vacciner vous l'avais dit il ya
peut-être une contradiction avec ces
adresses beaucoup plus solennelle qui
voilà qu'il qu'il adresse aux aux
français est ce que c'est un pari risqué
également pour lui justement de poster
une vidéo comme ça sur les réseaux
sociaux
bien sûr c'est un pari risqué moi je
pense que c'est inutile
concrètement c'est inutile je lui dirai
dit ça désacralise la fonction
présidentielle mais bon ça fait un petit
moment que est désacralisé doha la
fonction et puis surtout ce matin je
lisais avant de passer à l'antenne les
revues de presse et on lisait bon
finalement certains éditoriaux certains
commentateurs disaient qui finalement il
parlait un peu à tout le monde emmanuel
macron et essayer de lever les doutes
mais en fait ils manuellement quoi il
parlait pas du tout où je le répète où
je me sente ennemi le manifestant qui
manifestent depuis un certain temps et
pour un ce qui concerne les questions il
ya des questions qui vont être centrales
vous voyez d appel national de nombreux
hôpitaux aujourd'hui de soignants qui
sont en train d'être lancée dès le 4 ou
le 5 août donc ça je crois pas qu'il va
y répondre sans les problèmes de poids
il ne répond pas et finalement ne pas
répondre faire un petit stock un
histogramme parler aux jeunes non
vaccinés j'insiste il parle aux jeunes
d'en vacciner manuel mâcon il parle pas
que les français dans les réfractaires
ou les gens qui ont des doutes sur la
vaccination
effectivement je pense que c'est
dangereux c'est un pari très dangereux
et si finalement c'est une rhétorique
absurde pour moi qui va continuer je
vous le dis a crispé il a cristallisé
tous les gens qui sont dans la rue et
qui le seront probalement samedi
prochain encore en masse partout en
france
justement est-ce qu'ils n'arrivent pas
un petit peu trop tard ce message
puisque là on al impression qu emmanuel
macron fait de la pédagogie
justement concernant la vaccination et
c'est ce que l'on a reproché d'ailleurs
au gouvernement ne pas être assez
pédagogue d'aller au contact des
français pour leur expliquer vraiment ce
que c'est que la vaccination
oui ben se sont joués dans tes de tomber
dans la république des influenceurs tik
tok avec la rhétorique vous savez si le
vaccin au chômage
donc à partir de là quand vous n'avez
pas le choix soit c'est le chômage seul
vaccin c'est compliqué la pédagogie
elle a très peu d'effets finalement
comme vous êtes aussi martial et qu'on
vous dit c'est ça ou ça vous n'avez pas
le choix
uribe comme on n'essaie pas le ron aux
présidents républicains présents
république on le dit on le répète depuis
des années ça doit rassembler
ça doit rassembler le peuple et puis
légitimité aussi par rapport à une
population
le polonais légitime cas partout un mois
il à l'adhésion d'un grand nombre
d'habitants de france est bien entendu
il verser plus le cas donc il fait du
petit top pour parler aux jeunes mais
c'est une nouvelle fois désastreux que
très sincèrement c'est désastreux cette
communication
et puis en version selphy franchement je
ne sais plus quoi dépenser mois 2 du
manuel bac ou alors l'exécutif qui
surveille de très près justement les
manifestations la vue un samedi dernier
et plus de 200 mille personnes étaient
dans la rue pour voir la dénoncer à
l'extension du pass salutaire un chiffre
très élevé alors que nous sommes en
plein été à quoi faut-il s'attendre
justement dans les prochaines semaines
mais si emmanuel macron il ne fait pas
un post facebook d'ici aujourd'hui ou
demain ou après demain avec je vous ai
compris
mais il rend encore plus de monde doha
il y aura encore plus de monde
effectivement il y aura encore plus de
monde parce que les gens ne sont pas des
anti vaccins je le dis en permanence et
les handis pas sanitaire et ce sont des
gens qui sont épris de liberté publique
de liberty fondamentale et quand on leur
parle avec une telle morgue comme ignore
le nom de manifestants clamant qu on
désacralise l'aspect populaire et ben
manuel macro il va continuer à avoir
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de monde et
on verra bien mais à mon avis encore
beaucoup plus de monde et vous l'avez
dit c'est extrêmement important
nous sommes en plein mois de juillet
maintenant que vous me passez ans au
mois d'août et concrètement l'elysée et
matignon ne ricane se poser de sérieuses
questions aujourd'hui sur le module qui
va venir
merci beaucoup en tout cas nicolas vidal
d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes éditorialiste
politique